en cette période de crise sanitaire du
coville 19 les syndicats arriveront-ils
à mobiliser entre les français et les
organisations syndicales
l'heure est plutôt au désengagement et
ça depuis les années 60 mais j'ai
d'ailleurs au début des années 50 se
syndiquer ces courants 31,1 % des
salariés sont adhérents d'une
organisation
mais très vite les français tournent le
dos aux syndicats dix ans après en 1960
ils sont à peine 20% être syndiqués
pourtant certains restent convaincus
parce que papa avait toujours été
syndiqué et a considéré qu' un jeune
lorsqu'il commence à travailler doit
être indiquée pour défendre ses intérêts
dans les années 70 la tendance est à la
stabilisation avec 23 1 % de syndiqués
en 1975 mais les français se montre
critique envers des syndicats surtout
pas me mélanger politique et syndicale
mais relâché trop tard c'est trop tard
c'est fait pourquoi on irait dessus des
syndicats trop politisés pour y adhérer
résultat le pourcentage d'adhérents
dégringole moins de 15% en 1985 chez les
jeunes un sentiment d'abandon et
constater ma disons que je les connais
pas et en plus il se présente pas donc
aller devant des gens qui vous
connaissez pas c'est pas évident plus
les années passent et plus les adhésions
chute 1,2 pour cent des salariés étaient
syndiqués en 2013
le syndicalisme n'attire plus en cause
notamment des conflits entre les
organisations mais aussi l'augmentation
du nombre de travailleurs précaires
malgré tout les syndicats gardent une
place importante chez leurs adhérents ça
sert à quoi
rapport à nous défendre le faire évoluer
nos droits notre façon de travailler à
améliorer les conditions de travail
parce que c'est marcher dessus en france
d'après le dernier recensement
ouf % des salariés étaient syndiqués en
2016 c'est moins que la moyenne
européenne
de son côté la finlande est le pays le
plus syndiqués d'europe avec 73 %
d'adhérents